Third Night Today has been a dreary, rain
-soaked day, one without even the faintest trace
of sunlight.
It's as though the sky itself is reflecting
the gloom in my heart, the weight of
thoughts pressing down on me like the clouds
above.
The rain feels endless like the old age
that stretches out before me, colorless and joyless.
My mind is restless, swarming with strange, unanswerable
questions, each one darker and more oppressive than
the last.
These questions—so heavy, so impossible—seem to crowd my
brain all at once, leaving me feeling powerless.
I can't bring myself to resolve them.
Perhaps it's not for me to settle such
things.
Perhaps they are meant to remain unanswered.
Today we won't meet.
Yesterday, when we said good-bye, the sky
was already changing.
Clouds began to gather on the horizon, and
a thin mist rose, veiling the city in
a gray haze.
I remember mentioning it as we parted, almost
as if I could predict what was coming.
Tomorrow will be a bad day, I had
said.
But she said nothing in return, refusing to
acknowledge even the possibility of rain.
For her, the world was too bright, too
full of happiness to imagine otherwise.
If it rains, we won't see each other,
she had said simply.
I won't come.
I wanted to believe she wouldn't notice the
rain today, that her happiness would overpower any
storm.
But she hasn't come.
Yesterday was our third meeting, our third white
night, a night so pure and fleeting, glowing
with a light that seemed to promise eternity.
And yet, here I am, alone.
How radiant joy and happiness make a person,
how it fills every corner of their being.
Her heart was brimming yesterday, overflowing with love
and excitement.
You could see it in her every word,
every gesture, every glance.
It was as if she wanted the whole
world to share in her joy, to bask
in her happiness.
There was a warmth in her voice, a
tenderness in her words that made me feel
as though they were meant just for me.
How solicitous, how kind she was yesterday.
How she tried so earnestly to encourage me,
to lift my spirits.
Oh, the irresistible coquetry of happiness.
How easily it deceives.
While she laughed and spoke with such tenderness,
I—I believed it all.
I thought it was real, that it came
from her heart, and that it was meant
for me.
But my God, how could I have been
so blind?
How could I have fooled myself so completely?
How could I not have seen that everything
I thought was mine—her kindness, her smiles, her
gentle words—belonged to another?
None of it was truly mine.
Even her tenderness towards me, her attentiveness, her
affectionate concern—yes, even what I dared to think
of as her love for me was nothing
but an extension of her own joy, a
joy that didn't originate from me, but from
the thought of seeing someone else.
I was nothing more than a bystander to
her happiness, a piece of her world that
she wished to include in her glowing anticipation
of someone else.
When he didn't come, when her hopes went
unanswered, I saw her falter.
The lightness in her step, the gaiety in
her words—it all began to fade.
Her laughter grew quieter, her movements more hesitant.
And yet, strangely, she turned her attentiveness back
to me, almost as if by instinct.
It was as though, in the absence of
her own happiness, she was trying to pass
it on to me, to share what little
she could still muster.
I saw then how deeply she was affected.
My nastenka—yes, I still dared to think of
her as mine—was disheartened, dismayed, perhaps even heartbroken.
I think in that moment she realized the
truth—that I loved her.
She saw my poor unspoken love reflected in
my silence and in my eyes, and she
felt sorry for me.
When we are unhappy, it's as though we
become more attuned to the suffering of others,
as though our own pain sharpens our ability
to recognize it.
Instead of destroying our capacity to feel, sadness
concentrates it, heightens it.
She must have felt my sorrow, even as
she wrestled with her own.
I had gone to meet her with a
full heart, carrying with me all the anticipation
and impatience of someone who has allowed himself
to hope.
I had no idea then that it would
end this way, that my hopes would crumble
so completely.
When I arrived, she was already there, waiting
for me.
She looked radiant, her face aglow with pleasure.
She was expecting something—no, someone.
She was expecting an answer, and that answer
was him.
She had arrived long before I did, her
excitement so great that she couldn't wait.
At first she was giddy, laughing at everything
I said, even when it wasn't meant to
be funny.
Her laughter was infectious, but it didn't take
long for me to sense the undercurrent of
tension beneath it.
I tried to talk to keep the conversation
light, but soon I fell silent, unable to
match her mood.
I was too aware of the truth that
she couldn't yet admit to herself.
Do you know why I'm so happy today?
she asked suddenly, her eyes sparkling as she
turned to me.
Do you know why I like looking at
you so much right now?
Why?
I asked, trying to keep my voice steady,
though my heart was already pounding in my
chest.
I like you, she said with a warm
smile, because you haven't fallen in love with
me.
You know, in your place most men would
have been sighing endlessly, pestering me with their
feelings, making themselves miserable and me uncomfortable.
But you, you're different.
You're so nice about everything.
She laughed softly, but before I could respond,
she reached out and wrung my hand with
such unexpected force that I almost cried out
in surprise.
Her laughter grew brighter at my startled expression,
and for a moment her mood seemed to
lift entirely.
Goodness, what a friend you are, she said,
her tone shifting into something more serious, even
tender as her laughter subsided.
She gazed at me intently, and after a
pause she added, truly, God sent you to
me.
I don't know what I would have done
without you, especially now.
What would have happened to me if you
hadn't been here?
You are so unselfish, so kind, so understanding.
How could anyone be more genuinely caring than
you?
When I am married, you and I will
be the best of friends, closer than brother
and sister.
I shall care for you almost as much
as I do for him.
Her words pierced my heart.
In that moment a wave of profound sadness
swept over me, though I felt something else
too, an inexplicable urge to laugh.
Perhaps it was the absurdity of the situation,
the strange mingling of my love for her,
and the knowledge that she would never return
it.
You're very upset right now, I said gently,
trying to steady my voice.
You're frightened, aren't you?
You're afraid he won't come.
Oh, how unkind you are, she exclaimed, though
there was no anger in her tone, only
a kind of playful reproach.
If I were less happy, I believe I
would cry at your lack of faith, at
your doubts about him, and at the way
your scolding me now.
But no, I won't cry.
You've made me think, though.
Yes, you've given me a great deal to
think about, but not now, later.
For now, I must admit, you're right.
She sighed, her expression softening.
Yes, I am not myself right now.
I feel as though I'm floating, as though
everything is unreal.
My nerves are all on edge, and I
can't seem to feel things as deeply as
I should.
Everything feels too light, too fragile.
But enough about feelings, she said suddenly, cutting
herself off.
Let's not dwell on that.
At that exact moment we heard footsteps approaching.
The sound echoed faintly in the stillness of
the night, growing louder as the figure drew
closer.
In the dim light we saw a form
coming toward us.
We both froze.
She gasped softly, almost crying out, and I
instinctively let go of her hand and took
a step back, ready to walk away.
But the figure passed by without stopping.
It wasn't him.
What are you afraid of?
Why did you let go of my hand,
she asked, turning to me with a puzzled
expression.
Without waiting for an answer, she reached out
and placed her hand in mine again.
Come, it's nothing.
Let's wait together.
When he comes, I want him to see
how fond we are of each other.
How fond we are of each other, I
repeated, unable to hide the bitterness in my
voice.
Inside my heart ached as I thought, oh
Nastenka, Nastenka, how much you've just revealed to
me with those words.
Such fondness in moments like this makes the
heart grow cold and the soul unbearably heavy.
Your hand is cold in mine, while mine
burns like fire.
How blind you are, Nastenka, to the truth
right in front of you.
Oh, how unbearable a happy person can be
sometimes, and yet how could I ever be
angry with you?
The emotion swirling within me grew too intense
to contain.
At last my heart overflowed.
Listen, Nastenka, I burst out.
Do you have any idea how my day
has been?
Do you know what I've been feeling all
this time?
She looked at me with wide eyes, a
mixture of curiosity and concern.
What do you mean?
How has your day been?
Tell me.
Tell me quickly.
Why haven't you said anything until now?
Well, I began struggling to find the right
words.
To start with, after I carried out all
your commissions, delivering the letter, visiting your kind
friends, then—then I went home and went straight
to bed.
Is that all?
she interrupted, breaking into laughter.
Yes, almost all, I answered, trying to hold
myself together as foolish, inexplicable tears threatened to
well up in my eyes.
I woke up an hour before our appointment,
though, truth be told.
It felt as though I hadn't slept at
all.
I can't explain it.
I don't even know what happened to me.
It was as if time had stopped entirely,
as though the world itself had paused in
that one fleeting moment.
I came here to tell you everything, Nastenka,
feeling like that single sensation, that single overwhelming
feeling, had taken hold of me forever.
It was as if one minute of my
life had stretched out endlessly, as though it
could last for all eternity, and everything else—the
entire world—had come to a halt.
When I woke, it was as if some
old forgotten melody, one I had once known
so well long ago, but had since lost
in the recesses of memory, had returned to
me.
It was a tune so sweet, so achingly
familiar, that it seemed to echo deep in
my heart.
And I felt as though that melody had
been waiting there all along, knocking at my
soul, yearning to be heard.
And now, at last, it had broken through.
Oh, my goodness, my goodness!
Nastenka interrupted, her voice cutting through my reverie.
What on earth are you talking about?
I don't understand a word of it!
Her bluntness startled me, and I faltered, my
hopes dimming.
Yet there was still a faint, lingering hope
hidden in my voice as I tried to
explain.
Ah, Nastenka, I said plaintively, I was just
trying to describe to you that strange, overwhelming
impression.
Stop it, hush!
she said suddenly, and in an instant I
could see that she had guessed.
Her sharp intuition had uncovered what I hadn't
dared to say outright.
Her mood shifted abruptly.
With a mischievous smile, she became extraordinarily lively,
talkative, and playful.
She slipped her arm through mine, laughing with
a lightness that seemed almost calculated.
Every faltering, confused word I tried to speak
only made her laugh more, her laughter bright
and ringing.
Her amusement, so sudden and unrelenting, began to
irritate me.
It felt as though she was flirting deliberately,
as though she was trying to mask or
deflect something deeper.
Do you know, she began suddenly, still laughing,
I feel a little offended that you aren't
in love with me?
Isn't that strange?
How contradictory human nature is!
But then again, Mr. Unapproachable, she added teasingly,
you can't blame me for being so simple.
I tell you everything, every silly, foolish thought
that pops into my head.
It's just who I am.
Her words stung, though I tried not to
show it.
I glanced away, searching for a distraction.
Listen, I said, catching the faint sound of
a bell ringing in the distance.
That must be eleven o'clock.
The slow, deliberate chimes echoed faintly through the
quiet night.
She stopped suddenly, her laughter fading as her
expression changed.
She stood still, her face tense, and began
counting the strokes.
I regretted saying it immediately.
The look of nervous uncertainty in her eyes,
the way her voice trembled as she whispered,
yes, it's eleven, filled me with a sharp
pang of guilt.
Why had I done that?
Why had I deliberately reminded her of the
time?
I cursed myself for my petty impulse, for
the spiteful satisfaction I had felt just a
moment ago.
She was anxious enough already, and now I
had made it worse.
I wanted to take it back, to undo
the fear and sadness I had just caused.
Now, Stenka, I said softly, trying to comfort
her, don't worry, please, let's think this through
rationally.
There's no reason to believe the worst yet.
There are so many possible explanations for why
he hasn't come.
Let me explain, and you'll see it's not
as bad as it seems.
She looked at me, her eyes wide and
searching, desperate for reassurance.
I knew she wanted to believe me, to
hold on to hope, and it gave me
the strength to press on.
Look, I began, my voice growing steadier as
I warmed to my task.
It's entirely possible that he hasn't received your
letter yet.
Think about it, what if he wasn't at
home when it arrived?
He might not have read it, even now,
or perhaps he read it but wasn't able
to respond immediately.
There are so many reasons why he might
not be here yet.
Suppose he's planning to answer the letter but
couldn't come until tomorrow.
Anything could have delayed him.
As I spoke, I could see her tension
easing, her breathing slowing.
She wanted so much to believe me, and
I wanted even more to make her believe,
to ease her worry even for a little
while.
At that moment she was so vulnerable, so
ready to grasp at any straw of hope.
I continued, feeling a strange sense of responsibility,
almost a duty to shield her from despair.
I'll tell you what, I said finally, feeling
more confident now.
As soon as it's light tomorrow, I'll go
to check for his reply myself.
If there's an answer, I'll bring it to
you immediately.
We'll know for sure then.
But until that happens, don't let yourself think
the worst.
There are thousands of possibilities.
Anything could have happened.
She nodded slowly, her face softening as the
faintest flicker of hope returned to her eyes.
For a moment it seemed as though she
had found a little peace.
Yes, yes, said Nastenka eagerly, as though suddenly
awakened to a new possibility.
I didn't think of that.
Of course anything could happen, she added, though
her voice trailed off into a tone of
quiet resignation.
There was no real conviction behind her words,
only a faint, distant echo of another thought,
some vexing discord lingering in her mind, unresolved.
I know what you must do, she said
after a pause, her tone growing more certain.
Go as early as you can tomorrow morning,
the very first thing.
If you hear anything, anything at all, let
me know immediately.
You know where I live, don't you?
She began to repeat her address to me,
her voice hurried and yet soft, as though
she needed to make sure I would remember
every word.
Her insistence made me feel a strange pang
of sadness, a deep longing to reassure her,
to promise her more than I could.
Then quite suddenly her mood shifted, she became
unusually tender, almost maternal in the way she
looked at me, her concern for me clear
in every glance, every movement.
She listened attentively as I spoke, nodding slightly
as though she wanted me to believe she
was truly hearing me.
Yet when I asked her a question, she
faltered, her silence spoke louder than any words
might have.
Her confusion deepened and she turned her head
away, unable to meet my eyes.
I leaned in slightly, trying to understand what
was happening.
When she finally turned back toward me, I
saw it, tears glistening in her eyes.
She was crying, though she was trying desperately
to hide it.
Nastenka, I said softly, alarmed by her sudden
shift.
How can you?
Why are you crying?
Oh, what a child you are!
What childishness!
Come now, don't cry.
Please don't.
She tried to smile through her tears, brushing
them away quickly as though embarrassed by her
display of emotion.
It's nothing, she murmured, though her chin quivered
and her chest still heaved with the effort
to compose herself, she was fighting to steady
her breathing, to regain her usual cheerfulness.
But the struggle was written all over her
face.
After a moment of silence, she spoke again,
her voice softer, more contemplative.
I was thinking about you, she said, almost
to herself.
You're so kind, you're so good.
I would have to be made of stone
not to feel it.
Do you know what I was just thinking?
I was comparing you two.
She hesitated, then looked directly at me, her
eyes filled with strange mixture of sadness and
warmth.
Why isn't he you?
Why isn't he like you?
You are so much better than he is.
He isn't half as kind, half as thoughtful.
And yet—yet I love him more than I
could ever love you.
Her words pierced through me, leaving me speechless.
I couldn't summon a single response.
I didn't know what to say, and for
a moment neither did she.
She seemed to expect something, though, a word,
a look, anything.
But I stayed silent, struggling to contain the
storm of emotions her confession had unleashed within
me.
Perhaps, she said after another long pause, as
though trying to fill the silence herself, perhaps
it's just that I don't understand him fully
yet.
You know, I've always been a little afraid
of him.
He's so serious, so proud.
At least that's how he seems.
But I know it's only a facade, deep
down I know there's more tenderness in his
heart than even in mine.
I remember how he looked at me that
day, when I went to him with my
little bundle.
Do you remember?
I told you about it.
He seemed so kind, so sad.
And yet—I feel like I respect him too
much.
Doesn't that prove that we aren't equals?
No, Nastenka, I replied gently, my voice barely
above a whisper.
It doesn't prove that you aren't equals.
It proves that you love him more than
anything in the world.
More than yourself, even.
She looked at me with wide, thoughtful eyes,
as though my words had struck a chord
deep within her.
Yes, she said at last, her voice tinged
with naive sincerity.
Yes, maybe you're right, but do you know
what strikes me now?
She paused, her tone growing more reflective.
I'm not talking about him anymore, not about
anyone in particular, just speaking generally.
This is something I've thought about before.
Why can't we all just be like brothers
to one another?
Why is it that even the best people
seem to hide parts of themselves from others,
as if they're keeping something back?
Why can't we simply say what's in our
hearts, openly and honestly, especially when we know
our words won't be empty or meaningless?
Instead, we put up walls, we act distant,
and we make ourselves seem harsher than we
really are.
It's as if everyone is afraid to show
their feelings, afraid to express them too quickly,
as though they might somehow cheapen them by
doing so.
Oh, Nastenka, I said, my heart aching at
her words.
What you're saying is true, painfully true, but
there are so many reasons for it, so
many complicated reasons.
Even as I spoke, I felt myself suppressing
my own feelings more than ever, struggling to
keep my voice calm, to conceal the turmoil
raging within me.
No, no, she said suddenly, her voice charged
with deep emotion.
You, for instance, you're not like other people.
I don't even know how to explain what
I mean.
She hesitated, her words faltering as though she
was trying to grasp something intangible.
It's hard for me to put it into
words, but it seems to me that you,
right now, at this very moment, it seems
to me that you're sacrificing something for me.
Her voice softened as she added this, and
she glanced at me briefly, almost shyly, as
if afraid of my reaction.
Forgive me for saying so, she went on
timidly, her voice trembling as she tried to
keep her composure.
I'm just a simple girl, I've seen so
little of life, and sometimes I feel like
I don't even know how to say what
I want to say.
She smiled faintly, but there was a quiver
in her lips, as though she was holding
back something deeper, something she couldn't quite articulate.
I only wanted to tell you that I'm
grateful.
I feel it, deeply.
Oh, may God bless you for it.
May He grant you happiness, more than you
can imagine.
Her words were like a balm and a
wound at the same time.
She spoke with such sincerity that it was
impossible to feel bitterness, even as her meaning
pierced me.
What you told me about your dreamer, she
continued, is not true anymore.
Not about you, at least.
You've changed, you've recovered.
You're not the same man you described to
me.
She looked at me with something like pride,
as though she were acknowledging a transformation she
herself had brought about.
If you ever fall in love with someone,
really fall in love, I pray that God
grants you happiness with her.
I don't need to wish anything for her,
though, because she will be happy.
I know it.
I'm a woman, after all, and I understand
these things.
Believe me when I tell you this.
She fell silent then, her words hanging in
the air between us, and for a moment
neither of us could speak.
She pressed my hand warmly, her grip firm
yet tender, as though she wanted to convey
everything she couldn't put into words through that
single gesture.
I felt my throat tighten with emotion, but
I couldn't bring myself to respond.
The weight of her words, their bittersweet kindness,
held me silent.
Minutes passed in this quiet shared understanding.
At last she lifted her head and broke
the silence.
It's clear he won't come tonight, she said
softly, her voice steady but tinged with resignation.
It's late now.
I forced myself to reply, summoning all the
conviction I could muster.
He'll come tomorrow, I said firmly, as though
by sheer will I could make it true.
Yes, she said after a pause, and this
time there was no trace of her earlier
doubt.
Her voice was calm, almost cheerful.
I see now that it's impossible for him
to come before tomorrow.
Well, good-bye then, till tomorrow.
If it rains I might not come, but
the day after tomorrow I'll come for certain.
Whatever happens, I'll be here.
Promise me you'll come too.
I need to see you.
I'll tell you everything.
As we parted she gave me her hand
again, this time holding it longer, as though
she was reluctant to let go.
Her eyes met mine with a rare openness,
a kind of pure sincerity that took my
breath away.
We'll always be together, won't we?
she asked candidly, her voice filled with quiet
hope.
Oh, Nastenka, Nastenka, if only you knew how
lonely I am now.
When nine o'clock struck that evening I
couldn't bear to stay indoors.
The hours seemed to stretch endlessly, and the
walls of my room felt like they were
closing in around me.
I put on my coat and stepped outside,
indifferent to the damp chill of the weather.
The rain had eased, but the streets were
still slick and gleaming under the faint glow
of the streetlights.
I walked without direction, my feet carrying me
almost instinctively to the embankment.
There I sat on the bench we had
shared, staring out into the dark, restless waters.
After a while I found myself walking toward
her street.
My heart beat faster with every step, a
strange mix of anticipation and dread building within
me.
But when I was only a few steps
away from her door, I stopped.
Shame washed over me like a cold wave.
What was I doing?
I couldn't bring myself to look at her
windows.
I turned abruptly and walked away, my shoulders
hunched against the damp air, my thoughts heavier
than ever.
I returned home feeling more dejected than I
had ever been before.
The dreary day seemed to reflect my own
desolation, each raindrop a small echo of the
ache in my heart.
If the weather had been fine, perhaps I
would have wandered the streets all night trying
to escape my thoughts, but the rain drove
me back, forcing me to sit with my
loneliness.
Still I clung to the promise of tomorrow.
Tomorrow she would come, and she would tell
me everything.
Tomorrow would bring answers, resolution, perhaps even hope.
The letter hadn't arrived yet, of course, but
I told myself that was to be expected.
By now, I thought bitterly, they must already
be together.